EEMAフォローミーオーノーノーリッスン私は私たちです
ねえみんなドーゲンここで
私はこのビデオを数回録画しようとしました
が
、スクリプト化されていない即席のコンテンツが苦手なので、スクリプトを書くことにしました。
今日の通常の動画です。これは、
先週末、東京西部のYouTubeリトリートに行ったためです。
教育
からコメディー旅行、コメディー旅行、コメディー旅行、アニメの
ストリートレーシング写真のストーリー
テリングまで、コンテンツ表現の面で非常に親切で才能のある個人がリストに登場しました。 フルタイムの仕事のせい
で、クリエイティブな分野で働く人と話す機会が
あまりないので、リトリートでたくさんのことを学びましたが、その上、
そこにいたみんなはとても
謙虚で現実的な数人でし
た 何十万人ものチャンネル登録者と
、
ブログを書いている数人の人々と話をしたり、たむろしたりするのは本当に楽しいですが
、リトリートは出張というよりはグループでの休暇
だったので、
それほど深刻なことはありませんでした。  fビデオコラボレーション
など
、通常のコンテンツの代わりにチャンネル登録者が視聴できるものが欲しかったので、
このプロジェクトと旅行のいくつかのクリップ
を急いでまとめました。
約30分で出張する
ので
、このビデオの洗練度が不足していることを嫌悪感のあるWeb Webカメラの品質でお詫びし
ますが、日本の海外からのクリスにこのような素晴らしいイベントを開催
してくれた日本の幸せからアンドリューにもう一度感謝します
優雅な招待と、
出てきてとても楽しかったかもしれない他の
すべての人に、
YouTube
が日本で漂流する古典的なアニメの生活を書き
、マフィアのゲームをプレイする古典的な日本人について話
しているすべての人に会う素晴らしい時間を過ごしました。
何度も何度もトリッキーになり、何度も出てきた
ので、それは素晴らしいことですが、とにかく、これ
以上の苦労なしに
、YouTubeリトリートからの非常に非常に生のクリップがあり
ます。  eこれを少し楽しんでください。
他のメンバーのvlogや
ドキュメンタリーが
Twitterで公開されるときに共有する
か、このビデオや
今後のビデオ
にも彼らのビデオへのリンクを投稿します。 みんながこれよりもずっと洗練されているので、みんながそれらを見ることができ
ます。
出てきたみんなのおかげで本当に
素晴らしい時間を過ごしました。またお会いできるのを楽しみにし
ています。
多くの日本人
批評家ロジャー地元の
酒蔵があります。これは
ビアガーデンスタイルのセットアップのようなもの
です。基本的には、昼食をとった後
、自由に探索できますが
、駅のエモに戻る必要があります。
綿のようなホームレスのビッグボーイ
[音楽]
大丈夫な人のようにこれはドーゲンです
これは東京の西にあるYouTubeの集まり
でした私はディナがどこにいるのか思い出せ
ないので私はグマケンの漂流蒸気をカバーするアルボと一緒です
'再
漂流 ngは実際に生まれたので、私は走り回っているスポーツカーを購入し
ました。ジェットボート
に乗っていた友人の1人は、最初に
他の友人と一緒に漂流者を連れて
くるように誘ってくれました。
または私たち6人は全員ジェットアルトで、
クルーズやドライブに出かけます。
彼の車を見るたびに、彼
は人間のようではなく、漂流者
はアフリカから放り出されている
ようです。
ええ、私たちがアニメの
3つの有名な山のようにハーレムでそれをするのと同じ
ように、私はかつてのようでした。
彼が日本に来る前
はアーケードアニメではなくビデオゲームのように遊んで
いて、これが本物のようだとは知りませんでした
が、一度見たら
正確
にそうだったのです。
私は最初の意見なので、それはとても興味深いです Dは
、90年代のEuropopサウンドトラック
がその時代遅れのCG
と、新鮮でユニークなものと一緒に行く方法の大きな敵の1つです。つまり、
この時点でのストリートレースでのドリフトは、
猛烈な勢いで真剣にやり過ぎてしまいました。 でも
頭文字Dは
特にドリフトの原点のひとつでした。最近の
レース業界を知っているだけでなく、
以前は
海外で大きくなり
ました。長い間日本で大きかったのですが、
実際にはそうではありませんでした。
2000年くらいまで輸入され
ていたのは、通りすがりの仲間のようで、
まるでドラッグレースの
ように、ストップライトのそばに停車する船
のようでした。
杖を持った人のたわごとを見て、
彼は
これまでで最もたわごとのレスラーだったが、彼が出てきたので誰もが彼を愛していた
ので、
オートチェックを使用する現在の方法のように
、私のダークパンクは正しく
行いましたええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ ビッグ
ロックそれらは歴史のトップバンドだった
ので彼らは走りました赤ちゃんは
どこかから来たのでええ火なしで誰か他の人が間違って実現します
ええ
毎晩正しいことはできません
悪名高いインターネットユーザー
が鏡を見ると、
非常に真面目
で、フォスターの両親の階段の下のクローゼットに住んでいたクリスブライアンという男の子がいました
が、階段の吹き抜けには6つの階段しかありません
でしたが、クリスは例外的に 小さな子供
だったので、それは完全な取引破りではありませんでした
クリスは、休日の精神と薬物乱用
の家族の伝統を引き継いで叫んでいる階段を拡大しようと決心しました、
そしてこれを念頭に置いて私たちのh  eroは、ホリデーシーズンに
最高のカエルがすべてやってくるコロンビアに行くことにし
ました。
[音楽]